يتجدد الحديث عن امكانيه تزويد اوكرانيا
بصوارخ طويله المدى الولايات المتحده تدرس
هذه الاحتماليه يقول مسؤولون امريكيون ضمن
حزمه مساعدات جديده بقيمه مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار دون ان يحددوا نوع ومتى
الصواريخ الممكن ارسالها حتى الان جل ما
استلمته اوكرانيا من صواريخ لا يزيد مداها
على 100 كلم
وابرزها نسخه بيتريوت التي ارسلتها
الولايات المتحده ويصل مداها الاقصى الى
نحو 100 كيلو متر وهي صواريخ ارض جو
دفاعيه وليست هجوميه لكن عوائق كثيره تقف
امام توسيع استخداماتها اولها الحاجه الى
الصاروخين على الاقل الاعتراض هدف جوي
واحد
ويصل ثمنه كل صاروخ الى نحو ثلاثه ملايين
دولار ايضا تستخدم اوكرانيا منظومه صواريخ
هايبر يصل الى نحو 80 كلم وتسلمت
ايضا منظومات ام ال ار اس 270 البريطانيه
التي يصل مداها الى نحو 80 كم
التحفظ الغالب على تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
بعيده المدى يكمن في القدره على استخدامها
في ضرب العمق الروسي هذا فضلا عن مدى وفره
كميات السلاح لدى دول الغربيه المانحه
بشكل لا يؤثر على قدرتها العسكريه
فرنسا سبق ان حذرت من سيناريو مشابه وعشان
تمسك برفض ارسال اي سلاح بعيد المدى او
استراتيجيا كمقاتلتي اف 16 خشيه تاجيج
الزراعي في اوكرانيا وما لم تحدده واشنطن
حول مدى الصواريخ حذر منه الكريم بل وضع
ما قد يكون اقصى مدى يسمح به واعتبر
الكرام لان التزويد اوكرانيا لصواريخ يصل
مداها الى 150 كيلو مترا سيؤجج الصراع
اما اوكرانيا فتصر على طلبها رفع مستويات
السلاح الذي تتلقى من دفعه الى هجومي
وتاخذ في ذلك جولات من المحادثات مع
شركائها الغربي
[موسيقى]